this week on the climate show how do we
power all this when the sun doesn't
shine and the wind doesn't blow there's
a clue in the scooter
[Music]
hello and welcome to the climate show
with me Tom Heep and this week I'm
hitting the town in Liverpool not to cut
loose but to see how we keep the lights
on when energy demand is high but
Renewable Power is low
also this week a new report reveals that
we're pumping out more single-use
plastic than ever so after years of
campaigning and David Attenborough
documentaries why do we find it so hard
to bend the plastic habit
first climate friendly energy sources
like wind and solar rely on the weather
playing ball and when it doesn't we fire
up costly and expensive gas but as I've
been finding out here in Liverpool giant
batteries may help solve that problem
just as we finish work our electricity
system really puts a shift in whether
it's a night out or home for your tea it
adds up to the early evening being Peak
daily energy demand at the Abbey Road
sports bar the team are warming up
the manager knows customers are drawn to
the light even just walking down you
know the outside we want to attract our
customers and lights are an obvious way
to attract our customers to come inside
and keeping them demands yet more power
in our kitchens we've got Friars we've
got grills
our fridges then coming into the the bar
the bar area we've got we've got greens
through our
lights on the ceiling we've got our
fridges keeping all the drinks cold so
yeah plenty of appliances throughout
kitchen and the bar how important is
electricity to a venue like this
extremely important I mean people aren't
going to come here to sit in the dark
and have no entertainment or nothing to
look at keeping clean green energy
flowing through these things night and
day rain or shine is key and right next
door to here is one of the solutions to
that welcome to Europe's biggest grid
linked battery Sky News has been given
exclusive access just after switch on
can we have a look inside yeah yeah of
course
all of these containers have all of the
equipment in that we use to power the
local area and across the grid and how
much power can you store here so in
terms of the capacity of the site a good
example especially for a battery storage
company like ours is if you were to
charge 1 500 electric cars you would use
the whole capacity of the site
electricity generation can be patchy
with spikes and troughs especially in an
era of renewable energy
energy users need it smooth and
consistent otherwise the light dim or
the wires can melt
so what's in here hi well this is where
this battery site connects to a super
grid Transformer wow and on to the
National Grid that's a good reveal
that's a hell of a connector it is
so this is connecting up to 275
000 volts and this is the largest
Transformer to be connected to a battery
storage site in the UK
places like this remove the lumps saving
money and carbon well there's a huge
amount of Renewable Power that's
connecting onto the grid now and that
causes quite a lot of challenges because
it's not very consistent and so what
this site is doing is taking all that
power and sorting out those challenges
with intimacency and then putting that
power back onto the Grid in a very
consistent and predictable way for the
National Grid but also it's shutting
down the gas peakers that are currently
operating and as a result we save huge
amounts of CO2
one costly Quirk is when there is too
much solar or wind energy generators are
obliged to turn off and paid to do it in
millions sites like this are going to
reduce the amount of curtailment this
site itself will save somewhere between
50 and 100 million pounds to Consumers
over the next 15 years though this plant
cost many tens of millions storage on
this scale is only affordable now
because of the Boom in electric cars has
made batteries cheaper a good thing as
our Renewables heavy future rests on
storage we're going through one of the
biggest changes in our Energy System of
all time at the moment moving away from
fossil fuels and increasingly towards
renewable energy which of course is
variable so having energy energy storage
in the system is going to be a really
vital component of how the system works
in the future and makes and stays in
Balance to provide electricity for homes
and businesses renewable energy is the
future and I think that battery storage
is a real opportunity it offers so much
flexibility on the grid so for you this
stuff is as important as seeing a solar
panel or a spinning turbo just as
important yeah exactly
energy storage is one of the hottest
areas of Green Tech right now with
thousands of inventors and companies
working on ideas far beyond batteries
one of them involves this stuff right
here but you can't see it that's because
I'm talking about air liquifying air one
company involved is High View power and
their CEO Rupert Pierce reveals the
secret
well the easiest way to think about
Highview power is to is to think that
we're a freezer we're a freezer for
energy so we take the renewable energy
that otherwise wouldn't be usable in the
grid and we use that power
to freeze air and store liquid air in
very very large tanks 50 meter tanks uh
and that frozen air is ready to be
warmed up uh to become electricity again
we can hold those tanks full for weeks
or months of time back into the cycle
when the energy is needed we allow the
tanked energy to warm up the liquid air
becomes air again we drive it through a
turbine and it's used to make
electricity so it's renewable energy in
use that energy to freeze air into
liquid form store the energy of liquid
air and then warm it up when needed and
drive a turbine to come electricity
again it's brilliant in that it allows
us to capture the wind when it blows but
the market isn't there for it store it
and then recycle it back into green
power all over again when it's needed
and then
there's this not just the inspiration
for Sir Isaac Newton falling things are
a source of energy and Scottish company
gravatricity wants to use that by having
very heavy weights in very deep old
Minds
we're looking to utilize either existing
mines or new shafts
to suspend a solid weight
the weight is suspended via cables and
attached to electric winches when there
is Surplus electricity on the Grid
electric winches can be turned and the
cables which are attached to the weight
allow that weight to raise when the
weight is in the in a higher position it
is storing electricity in in the form of
potential energy when we want to give
electricity back to the grid the weight
is lowered using the energy that's
stored with gravity and that in turn
rotates an electric winch which turns a
generator and puts the electricity back
onto the grid
we've identified that across Europe
there are significant number of Mines
which are closing out present so they're
reaching the end of their service life
that presents a really interesting and
exciting opportunity for us to repurpose
these end-of-life assets
there's something really nice about
knowing the energy infrastructure of the
past can be repurposed to help us with
our transition to the cleaner
electricity grid that we hope for
well another storage idea that I've
heard about is something called a sand
battery using an incredibly widely
available and pretty cheap material now
the people who are really ahead of this
are the fins and I'm joined on Zoom by
Marco leonen who's developing this thing
marku what is a sound battery just
simply put it it's a huge container
containing hot sand that is used for
heating up homes or potentially
industrial processes or well whatever
that requires relatively or medium to
high temperatures so this isn't about
electricity this is about heat but heat
is incredibly important in our energy
story isn't it
complete accounts to something like 70
or 80 percent of the emissions in the
energy sector well if you look at almost
any manufacturing process
heat is involved and quite often it's
produced by burning gas oil coal
well combustion base anyway and also
heating up homes it's a significant
factor in uh in well in global CO2
emissions
and how do you get the energy into the
sand and how do you get it out we have a
really simple
approach to heating up the sand uh so
nowadays we have a lot of wind power and
and solar power available we have a lot
of clean and affordable energy well
sometimes it's it goes even to waste so
it means that sometimes electricity is
rubbish we use Simple uh resistive
heating elements to to heat up air that
passes through a piping system inside
the sand and and therefore heats up the
sand so instead of wasting that energy
when you've got too much uh too much
wind for instance you can literally
convert it into a into a heating element
that's then heating air that goes
through the sand yeah well uh resistive
heating is something well
as always anything related to
electricity uh so that's a simple
technology it's the old bar heaters for
for people of my age can remember those
used to be in our homes or indeed what
made old-fashioned light bulbs hot isn't
it it's it's what made the filament hot
and glow
exactly we get the
energy out by using the exact same
piping systems our product is then hot
air that we can put into well many
different kind of directly inside into a
process one of our more important
sectors in the industry has now been for
example food and and beverage industry
what kind of food and drinks are you
talking about there give me some
examples baking bread requires something
like 300 degrees Celsius to the ovens
and then uh and then well breweries are
a really potential one for us bread and
beer what's not to like yeah exactly
after the break we'll be turning our
attention to plastic and asking why
despite all our efforts we're
creating more of this stuff than ever
before could a new Global treaty be the
solution
[Music]
welcome back to the climate show now let
me take you back a few years to when
David attenborough's Blue Planet 2 had
just come out provoking outrage about
plastic in the sea
Sky launched its ocean rescue campaign
many of us tried to shame Brands into
using less plastic there was a plastic
bag tax a pushed back against plastic
straws and we discovered the virtues of
reusable bottles well it turns out that
none of that has done anything to stem
the growing tide of using single-use
Plastics
a new report shows that despite raising
awareness and regulation
139 million tons of plastic was
generated globally in 2021 an increase
of 6 million tons on 2019's levels and
that's really bad for Waste but also for
the climate
greenhouse gas emissions over the life
cycle of single-use Plastics in 2021
were equivalent to the total emissions
of the whole of the UK but recycling is
not proving to be the solution
98 of the new plastic produced is what's
known as virgin plastic made from fossil
fuels and just two percent comes from
recycling
unfortunately voluntary commitments are
not going to get us out of this crisis I
think you know what we've seen is that
you know consumer pressure voluntary
commitments from companies you know a
little more political awareness like
that is not changing the trajectory the
problem is getting worse
um so you know we really need like big
interventions
so despite smothered sea creatures and a
pollution Menace our Global passion for
plastic seems unquenched so could law
succeed where campaigns have largely
failed interest is growing in an
international treaty to work on this
area and I'm with one of the people who
is working on it that's a Chris Dixon
from the environmental investigation
agency Chris what would this treaty be
okay so in a best case scenario we're
going to have a global legally binding
instrument that deals with the full life
cycle of plastics so basically from the
moment that plastic is conceived as a
material to the end of its life so
whether that's kind of in the
environment or from a kind of waste
management and leakage perspective so
covering that full spectrum of plastics
as a material so what would that oblige
countries or companies to do say in the
production phase first of all so what it
could do and one of the things that
we're really pushing for is to have
restrictions on polymers so right now I
mean we have billions of polymers being
created there the build
everything that we have that's made of
plastic comes from these polymers but we
don't really know the ingredients of
them but we know that some of them are
containing for example harmful chemicals
and additives and we know that some of
them are not necessary they could
actually just be phased out immediately
so what we could see the treaty doing is
essentially capping and phasing down and
phasing out the production of some of
these polymers and a smaller range of
polymers also makes them easier to
recycle I gather exactly although you
know I think we have to be really
careful when we talk about recycling as
a solution to the Plastics crisis
because as we know only about nine
percent of plastics that have been
created have actually been recycled will
this treaty have something on the
disposal of plastic you weren't too keen
on recycling but at least it's about
pollution so keeping it out of the
natural world absolutely this treaty
will have obligations at every stage of
the Plastics life cycle so that would
include obligations on production
product design but of course on waste
management and waste management
infrastructure preventing leakage you
know leakage is a huge area that we need
to address but there is already quite a
lot happening on that Downstream side
and there's no a lot happening on the
Upstream side and in all those things
would it be about reducing for instance
the carbon emissions in creating the
plastic or regulating leakage from from
the refineries for instance yes
yeah it's really interesting to think
about you know what the scope of this
treaty could actually be because we have
at the moment you know oil and gas
companies they're really investing in
plastic as a kind of plan B to reduce
Demand on the energy side so we're
seeing huge build out of petrochemical
facilities and actually we need to
really think about is that build up
build out what we need it's carbon
intensive it's locking us into a system
that we're actually trying to move away
from so the treaty for example could
issue a moratorium on the building of
new petrochemical facilities actually
reducing the amount of plastic created
yeah I mean we can't really do anything
without reducing the amount of plastic
that we're currently creating like this
is an unsustainable model is plastic bad
that's a really really tricky question
my phone case is made out of I think
because some of you coating on your
bottle there your reusable water bottle
is made out of it I mean we find it so
difficult to shed ourselves of it
because it's so useful yeah I think that
plastic you know is always going to
exist in some cases you know there'll be
some essential uses and within a treaty
on plastics it's not saying we're going
to get rid of all plastics for every
application it's saying what are the
Plastics that we're currently producing
are they necessary are they safe do they
contain toxic chemicals are they
actually necessary at all could that
application of plastic be either
replaced with a different material or
ideally a different system of delivery I
think that's why there's such a big
movement around the concept of you know
reuse systems like keeping materials in
circulation you know true circularity we
don't need to keep extracting in order
to to live Our Lives why do you think
campaigns well I'll put it to you have
failed you know our appetite for plastic
is going up not down despite all the
passion here we can see it around us
here yeah well I wouldn't I wouldn't
personally say that you know we failed
as campaigners I think the fact that the
global Community has actually agreed to
negotiate a new legally binding
instrument to end plastic pollution
that's like the title of the resolution
and plastic pollution and that is the
United Nations we're talking about it's
not it's not nobody I think that
demonstrates the power of the campaigns
that have been raising awareness about
plastic pollution but one of the
challenges is that a lot of the
communications and narrative has been
around pushing obligations onto the
consumers you know if you reuse your
bottle or you know if you say no to
plastic straws you can address the
Plastics crisis and that is absolutely
Bonkers narrative we really need to be
thinking about a complete system change
that doesn't rely on the continual
extraction of natural resources and the
rampant production of single-use
plastics like we don't need items that
we're just going to use once to be
wrapped in Senegalese plastic and then
thrown away but you will be asking
countries and companies who make a lot
of money out of this business to stop
doing it they're just going to say no or
weasel their way out of it like we see
with fossil fuels aren't they well
that's what we're really hoping that a
treaty is going to help to address and I
think the fact that there's Global
appetite around legally binding measures
um that's that's a really strong
starting point but what we need to do is
also you know learn lessons from for
example the climate agreement and think
about the role of these massive Plastics
producers what is their role in the
negotiations should they have an equal
voice to for example communities living
in the defense line communities living
where petrochemical facilities are being
built you know that is not an equal
Dynamic when might we see the treaty
coming in and maybe regulation over it
so the negotiations are going to
conclude by the end of 2024 with the
agreement open for adoption in 2025 so
we're really going to start seeing some
real movement on this in 2025. well
thanks very much Chris we all know how
difficult it can be and Chris has
alluded to it to cut down our own use of
plastics but there is an idea that
involves something from ages past who
remembers the milk float
my name's Ella and I'm the founder of
Top-Up truck top up truck is a mobile
zero waste shop that helps people cut
down on their plastic packaging from the
convenience of their own Street by
bringing the shop to them on an electric
milk float
I set it up because I believe that the
continued use of single-use plastic is
an Abomination and even though I think
that I myself wasn't finding the time in
my schedule prior to setting this up to
actually get to the zero waste shop so I
thought how do we make it more
convenient or what if the zero way shot
came to me
hiya how's it going what are you after
today
sure
[Music]
so obviously plastic is made made from
fossil fuels and it's completely
unnecessary the degree to which we're
using it it's driven by Supply rather
than by demand we don't actually need it
there's so many ways that we can kind of
innovate around it obviously it's it's a
very it's very practical because it can
get food products very safely and
cleanly to people at a very low cost but
the fact of the matter is it stays
around for years and years and years and
and it's just not needed
that's great thank you
I think we need a variety of ways and a
variety of options for people in terms
of refill offerings that are out there
in the market and thankfully we're
seeing a proliferation of different
angles on it in terms of things getting
ordered via direct mail and delivered to
people's doorstep in returnable
containers we're seeing it happen in
supermarkets obviously there's loads of
amazing independent
um sort of bricks and mortar zero wave
shops as well
there we are
the Top-Up truck can help proliferate
the number of access points to refill
particularly in kind of dense urban
areas with more and more different
solutions it just offers consumers
different ways that they can avoid
single-use plastic
[Music]
now I want to mention a report just out
from the International Energy agency
which says we're close to reaching a
very significant Tipping Point now we
associate tipping points with being a
bad thing but in this case it's about
our Energy Mix and the fact that in just
two years Renewables and nuclear will
meet all the world's new electricity
demands and start to displace fossil
fuels too that means emissions from
generating electricity which have
continued to rise globally will finally
start to fall
and now just before we go a reminder
that you can catch the daily climate
show at 3 30 p.m weekdays on Sky News
and you can get all the latest climate
and environmental news on the Sky News
app or website or by scanning the QR
code on your screen right now
and if you have a burning question about
the climate scan the QR code on your
screen right now and we'll do our best
to answer it in future shows
and that's it from here on the banks of
the mersey join us next week when we'll
be looking at plans for future cities
and why they're generating such
controversy see you then
[Music]